[Music]
welcome back guys demo rpg episode
13.
all right we're gonna write unit tests
uh this episode that's the main goal so
there's a couple core things we got to
do first of all
this uh program it's just an application
we can hit play it runs we need to turn
this into a library instead
that way we can actually make tests that
use it so the first thing we got to do
is just turn this into a library and
there's a couple key things we got to do
here to turn this into a library but on
visual studio if you're following along
with the same editor you can just do it
through the properties of your project
so these are basically compiler commands
uh so you can look up how to build
things into a library because of course
you can do it on linux and stuff too but
make sure your configuration is just set
to all configurations and all platforms
essentially editing these properties is
the same as just changing your compiler
commands so hope that makes sense but uh
that's what we're doing here we went to
it and right under general here you see
configuration type we need to change
this from application
to a library we need to decide if it's a
dyna if it's a dynamic library or a
static library i think for now we're
just going to go with static library
it's small enough i think that a dll
doesn't we don't need to make it a diy
if you're reusing it a ton in a bunch of
different programs dll is probably
better
because it just exists in one place and
it uses the dll at run time the static
library is at build time so that's the
main difference there we're going to go
with just static live because it's small
enough we're mostly just doing some
simple code there's nothing too heavy in
here yet so i think static life's fine
and i personally have more experience
with static lives so i'm going to fumble
less but either way is technically fine
if you want to do dll you can go through
the steps of making it a dll there's
just a few changes really it's not it's
not a whole lot different but it is
going to be different how you use it so
anyway we're sticking with static live
and then we're just going to go with
that that is the main thing we need to
do here is just change this to static
light so if you're using something where
you're building with command line or
using cmake you can look up how to build
as a library and you will find something
similar where you just change
something in your build command your
type and the next big thing we need to
do is basically get rid of our main but
we still do need everything
all these dot h files to build into some
kind of object file which is essentially
a cpp file is going to turn into some
kind of object but
a library does not need a main because
it's not where it runs so our all this
main code is going to go into a test so
we're going to jump around a little bit
here and just go to our solution and uh
right click it or oh yeah there's
multiple ways to do this you can just go
file
new
uh let's see
or add rather
add new project here if you add new
project from file that'll do it
it'll pop up this window
and you want to look for a native
unit test
there are other unit tests there's a lot
of them i just put a community post on
on my channel here
asking a bunch of you what you think's
the best so you're welcome to use any of
them you're basically going to have to
follow a getting started tutorial if
you're using a different one
realistically they all work fine uh i've
tried a lot of them there's no problems
i'm using this one because well because
it's really easy as you can see we just
basically hit new project click this
native unit test and uh hit next and we
give it a name
and we're just going to call this rpg
systems
unit test and then create
and it's that simple all right so now we
have your c over here on the left
we have two projects going on we got
demo rpg and we got rpg systems unit
test so this unit test is essentially
the application now at least for testing
it's a little different but that's how
we kind of need to think of it if we try
to run this demo rpg it's just going to
fail in fact we can try and watch what
it does builds okay but then it goes
unable to start program it's not a valid
132 application that's because it built
as an rpg.live you can't run a dot live
you got to use it in another program all
right so let's go back to our unit test
and we're going to right click on it go
to properties and we're just going to
change oh this is a dynamic library okay
interesting
it i guess it operates in a special way
but basically what we want to do is we
want to go to the includes here or let's
see the linker and then the input ah
we're doing this the hard way nevermind
cancel out of this
there's a little simplified way of doing
this you just right click and go add
reference
and then check demo rpg so now it's
going to include demo rpg
as a library essentially so it's going
to know about this dot live that gets
built from demo rpg
is all this reference is going to do so
anytime you build these tests it's also
going to build any references all right
we're going to change this to file view
show all files that way we can actually
see what's going on
and if we go to this rpg system unit
test it just gives gives you a cpp with
the same name as your main file
or as the test
we'll see we get this boilerplate code
it includes your pre-compiled header
it includes cpp unit test
and it does using name stave
namespace visual studio you know test
framework etc then it puts you in a
namespace for this particular test
and then it starts doing some macro
stuff here like this test class macro
you can hover over it and see what it
exactly does if you want but you can see
it gets a class name and it
inherits from
the test class framework uh you don't
really need to worry about that a whole
lot but essentially what we're going to
do here is we're going to have these
test methods within a test class
and
these are all going to run asserts and
this is the name of it so let's just do
a first one that says
um
great warrior
and let's just see if it properly
creates a warrior
or maybe we'll call it a warrior test or
something like that we can change this
on the fly if we need to a little bit
all right and essentially what we want
to do here in this test method is what
we were doing in our main with the
warrior and just confirm that it works
so we'll be we'll be getting rid of this
main as we go so let's just take this
player character here and
cut it
and paste it in here now it doesn't know
what player character is it doesn't know
warrior is that is because uh of course
you need to include it and including
it's a little different because watch we
just try to include
a player character or warrior it doesn't
really see them
and it's because
well
it's the direct structure so i'm going
to explain this in two different ways
i'm going to first explain it the way i
would not do it but just an fyi so if
you right click on this and just open in
file explorer or just right click and
press x that's the fast way it'll open
up a file explorer with this
setup so this is where we are you need
to go back a directory then into the
demo rpg directory and then you have all
this stuff so you could go okay backup
directory into the demo rpg directory
and then include what you need to
include
however if folders get changed and moved
around this won't work well because well
the file structure will change but
really this is fine you can see it now
sees those what i tend to do i think
this is a little more consistent is just
make it include a directory with the
build you can find out how to do that
with command line stuff it's just a dash
i i think and then the paths but uh in
this
test we just go to properties once again
and i realize that my face is probably
covering some of these options so i'm
going to move up here
all right right click go to properties
and we want to look for vcc directories
we'll see include directories
really important i probably should have
mentioned this when i when we change the
input but make sure your configuration
is just set to all configurations in all
platforms otherwise you might get some
oddities when you switch these around
because it's going to change how it's
compiling and we just want to add now
from this vcc directories or whatever it
is uh v plus v c plus plus it's hard to
say all right just uh and this include
directories we're gonna type in at the
end here a special thing you can click
this little carrot if you want go to
edit and you get a fresh line here
and click on
we're going to start with solution dir
solution dirt so that's a
money sign open parentheses
solution
there's one word in
whatever this caps case uh
okay so solution dir
now if we click out here it actually
tells you the evaluated value basically
it is the directory to the project so
all the way to demo operation top level
now it does include the trailing slash
solution der has the trailing slash
already that's kind of important so we
don't need to put that but where do we
go from here we go into once again the
demo rpg folder
then another slash and then typically we
want include however
we don't have an include folder in demo
rpg it's just all flat which is okay
but we're going to make it include
so let's just do that for now
and then we'll make that include and get
that straight now all right so it's got
its path now for all configs and all
platforms now let's go back to demo rpg
and just go add
new folder
include
we're going to take all these dot h
files and just put them in there
and that's going to automatically sort
out the structure
all right move all these dot h's
always.h is very good
so now the paths are correct and it
should since we moved it through visual
studio it should have automatically
updated the build
stuff like these project files it should
have corrected their paths
already so that's fine okay and that
just kind of allows us to more carefully
analyze which stuff we should be
including
in
uh projects that use this library that's
all it really does it's technically
optional
but people tend to do it in fact people
tend to go a step further and have even
another folder of the project name again
like so and then put it into there just
so that when you're you're including it
you'll have to go like this and it's
clear where you're getting player
character from
uh so
i find that to be somewhat optional in
smaller cases but let's just go ahead
and do it so i'm going to select all
those and drag them into that say okay
and now this is happy and the project is
already updated over here because we
moved it using visual studio so it
corrects all the stuff it needs to
correct when you do it that way if you
go into the folder and manually copy
paste it it's going to get real confused
over here because
it is not processing the changes you
have to manually go update the project
file if you do it that way or you know
if you're using cmake you got to update
the paths on cmake et cetera and same
with the make file for using a make file
but i don't want to dive too much into
build systems that's kind of a side
topic and something i'm kind of
expecting you to research on your own if
you get stuck on that kind of stuff but
i'm going to at least go over what i'm
doing here so that if you're following
along exactly you won't have too much
trouble okay so there we go we've got it
sorted out in a new way
we do have to look at these cpp files
because if we look at item it doesn't
know where item now is
so we got to say uh it's in include demo
rpg
and then item
now if you don't want to do this every
time for this main project you can do a
similar thing you can right click go to
properties on the demo rpg
all platforms all configs and just give
it also the include path
and on this one we just want uh project
er
let's go ahead and click and see what
that resolves to as you can see it
resolves all the way to demo the demo
rpg project
and then you can just type in include
and then demo rpg
and there we go
so now
all the files
and this are going to understand these
headers without having to to path to
everyone so that's kind of nice
and we'll be fixing this as we go but we
just want to get these basic tests in
place and building all right so let's go
back to the unit test check out our
warrior
and it looks like it's happy here
uh we want to run some tests uh we want
to do some stuff with the warrior so
first of all let's just assert
and i believe you got to go
yeah view assert scope it's going to
give you some options of what you could
do so we want a skirt a skirt assert is
not null
p1 i guess
well
p1 is not a pointer
so if we look at this class and we got
stuff here
what can we get that returns a pointer
is there anything we can get that's
going to be a good test
not really
we could get like the backpack list or
something
but it's not null it's not a good test
it's really it
it's it won't it won't construct right
if that's failing so that's maybe not
the best test let's continue on a little
bit here
all right so if we look at our main and
just see what we were doing with the
warrior sure we were equipping him with
stuff that's all well and good but we
don't particularly want to test
equipping in this test this one is just
specifically to see if a warrior creates
so that should be fine
let's just uh let's see we got all this
big for loop of we were just like kind
of saying his abilities and weapons and
all that stuff let's just cut all that
for the moment
and paste over here we're not going to
use the same let me get this stuff out
of the way it's pretty ugly uh we don't
want to do any see out see outs are like
uh no let's not you know let's not do
that all right so let's just level him
up so
uh there's where's the level up code it
is
see on the second iteration i think we
were doing that yeah so it's way at the
bottom let's just we gained some xp you
know we just gained some xp all right
so we'll just do that gain xp
and then we'll assert
we'll just assert that he's level two
r equal p1 dot
get level
and two
so this
returns a level type uh so we probably
want to cast this two to level type as
well just to make sure that our equal is
successful
like so
and uh player character is already party
has types i hope
doesn't doesn't seem to find it too
easily it might after a reload or
something but f12 does not work here
right now it's just a visual studio bug
i would assume at this point
but uh yeah so if we look at types
or sorry player character it already
includes all this stuff
so technically we have all this stuff in
our test file as well since we've
included it here
and
that's kind of just an fyi sometimes you
want to make it clear and actually
include stuff in this as well that
you're using like we should probably
just
you know copy this down and put types
here just to just to be really clear
but uh yeah that should be fine so the
rest of this code
it's kind of whatever
let's just let's just comment it out for
now so i'm just gonna select it all and
just hit control
ac which is just a
hotkey there so all this is gonna do is
make a new warrior give him a hundred xp
and assert that he's level two
and that that's a fine test so we should
be able to build this and run it now
except there's gonna be a few issues
that will address as they come up
uh so let's go ahead and do this and to
build tests now this is this is clutch
because
if you don't know how to do this you
just you'll just be stuck here you go up
to the top you go to test
test explorer or you can hit the hotkey
control e then t let's hit ctrl e then t
oh i hit r oops
there it goes that's the same as going
to test test explorer it'll bring up
this new little test explorer box here
if you're using a different test system
you'll have to look up how to do it on
yours but essentially all we do here is
just hit run all tests and it should
build everything it needs and we're
going to get some errors we're kind of
expecting that
most of these are from the main where we
cut out code
so let's just go ahead and take this
whole main
and let's just get rid of all that we'll
just comment it out for now we'll clean
it up by the end but just so our test
succeeds all right now let's hit play
again
in fact we really don't even want this
main we got we got some more errors
uh let's even just get rid of this mean
all right so we'll call it out main
we're probably going to get some more
errors say build again
yeah we got some more errors so we want
to see what the build errors actually
are it's kind of hidden so we can hit
build and just see what it complains
about
let's have a look now
let's see we get some static asserts
something about two string
something about level type all right
well i'm pretty sure the main problem
here
is that these are all just dot h files
they need something to actually build
into so doing this code all in the dot h
files
is not really good practice for a
library the library should only forward
what people need to know about the dot
lib is actually what's going to include
all the definitions so us having all the
definitions
in our dot h's is going to be a little
weird sometimes and we're going to get
strange bugs basically probably what
we're running into here most likely it
doesn't look like it like if you try to
analyze this it seems like there's a
problem with the tests
and maybe there is i think it doesn't
like
comparing our items
type let's just see if this fixes it so
all right forget about this level type
here
let's just cast this
to whatever this ends up being so this
is a
just a plain old two here
uh it should be an integer so if we just
go like hint
level
equals two let's paste it in here just
to make sure it's actually a in it and
we'll just uh cast this to an end as it
checks
so let's just try that so these
are equals see all these are macroed and
uh templated so maybe it's not good at
specializing to certain unsigned instant
things so that's i think what we're
running into but let's just hit build
again and see what happens
and okay yeah that was it seems happy
succeeded it's going to run this first
test and it succeeded it passed the test
which means this assert
was
successful it did find that git level
was two so our first test is successful
if you got this far give yourself pat on
the back congratulations you made your
first test and uh from here
we just extrapolate essentially we just
keep going uh you just make new cases
you keep asserting and you just keep
building up these tests until they're so
large that nobody wants to look at them
but you know they work and anytime you
build new stuff you build tests or you
can build a test first and then write
the code to pass the test and that's
essentially what we're gearing towards
now this test method is called warrior
test so given its name
like if we go down here we see we got
warrior tests and you can see how it's
scoped and everything down here
given its name we only want to test
warrior stuff that's basically what
we're looking at here
but uh let's you know that's
that's all well and good but let's go
ahead and
cut that out all that extra stuff we
don't really need it anymore uh let's
just see if we can actually
put
this 2 in here and it still succeeds so
let's say run all again should rebuild
still passes okay
just checking but let's see what happens
if we take this int cast off of this
let's just have it have a check because
this returns an unsigned and this is a
different type so these being different
types is probably going to confuse it
and it does as expected we got an error
they're complaining about level type so
we do need to cast these to ends to run
this test correctly just because
uh
yeah it's just not overloading correctly
even if we give them both
that level type it seems to not have a
template that handles
whatever our level type is and we can go
look at our level type it's a unit 16.
apparently this r equal doesn't have an
overload for that so that's more on
their unit test than us and yeah we get
a complaint about a template so
just just checking that out there
so apparently you're not allowed to use
un-16s in this thing right okay whatever
we'll just make do with some casting and
it'll be fine we can move on
all right let's check that our warrior
actually got the abilities he's supposed
to get so let's go to our warrior and
let's go to his level up
and he should get power attack
all right so we can just check that he
has power attack
uh so let's go back to our test and we
should be able to go assert
our equal
p1.get well we have getabilitylist.first
we'll
return the first thing and then it
should be
power attack
so this returns a vector of abilities
the first thing in that abilities
should be
oh we need dot name we need the name of
it
okay
dot first dot name
see if that works
we gotta do it like that
i don't know there's something here
that's hitability list
front i'm sorry stop front
dot name so this should return a string
of power attack
doesn't like this operator for some
reason
uh let's just see what happens
let's try to test this now testing
strings so it's kind of a little awkward
it's not about you evaluate to a
function taking zero
arguments
so maybe we have to go something like
this
just say it's a string compared to a
string
no that's not it either all right so
yeah testing
versus strings is a little bit different
you usually don't want to do this
usually you want to do these tests with
hard numbers and not with character
arrays because character arrays are a
little more fidgety
and maybe you already caught this but
dot name is not a function it doesn't
need brackets that's probably the the
true complaint here and now it's going
to say it doesn't understand the
overload
because this here is returning a string
and this here is a const care array so
we just want to make this a string
and it might be happy if it's got a
proper template for that looks like it
does so let's just hit uh run all tests
again
see if it builds the new one
looks like it does
and did it actually run the test it
appears to let's just make this fail
let's put a d in there just typo it and
hit run all again just see if it fails
and it does
and it gives you some info assert
expected a power attack actual
power tac d all right it tells you
exactly where it failed so that's that's
the key stuff once you have a bunch of
working tests you can run them and see
what's failing and it's very nice
now the way this is worded
it looks like you're supposed to put the
correct answer first and then what it's
supposed to be or what it actually
became second so just the way it's
wording expected power attack actual
power tech d it looks like it's uh yeah
we should have the real thing first than
what it's getting from your library
second that should fix the wording a
little bit we have some basic warrior
test we test that he actually gets to
level two tests his name we should test
more stuff we should test that his
health is correct we should just run the
full suite of all the tests on on this
guy our equal
we should check before he levels and
after he levels and we could like fully
level him up to max level with this test
and just assert that the warrior works
perfect and as you might have kind of
figured out just by me saying that
it takes a lot of time to write tests
but if you've got a really clear plan
for exactly what you want to happen you
can put it all in the test code and then
build up to it and that is essentially
test driven development and we could do
that we could we could have a little
chart that we could you know sit down in
a coffee shop or whatever away from a
computer and write down exactly how we
want the warrior to go like level 1 to
10 or however far you want to go
and then just put it all in a test
and then build it all up make sure the
tests all pass and you can you can
pretty firmly assert that your warriors
working correctly and then if you later
just change some some code somewhere and
it breaks something in the warrior level
up you will know and you you can do that
for essentially everything
and um the benefit to this is now it's
extremely clear and well tested that you
you know when your program's working
correctly
and that's a really good thing because
if you just build a giant code base
without tests uh you can sure you can
put a main and throw a few things in
there but like is everything really
working correctly you don't know unless
you have a nice suite of tests
and that's that's really the whole point
here so let's assert that his health is
correct so if we go to warrior we can
look at his base hp it's 18. pretty
thick number
so we can go b1 dot get
base
or i guess it's get hp
now we could even assert that it is well
a little bit tricky because like we know
it's 18.
what if that changes right and we need
to cast these to integers otherwise it's
going to do the same complaint as before
right so we assert that he starts with a
18 hp so if we go into the warrior and
we change this
it's going to break the test code so
maybe
we actually want
this is static cons so we can scope to
warrior base hp and assert that it it is
correct uh like so uh let's go
warrior base
hp since this is a static const this is
a valid variable right here and we want
to make this an integer as well
oh we need one more there we go
and that should work
and then later
after he levels up for example we want
to assert that his max hp is
is better uh so this this should fail
right but we could figure out what it
should be by
you know basically looking at let's go
back to warrior here
uh what happens when he levels up how
much hp does he gain
well he gains base hp divided by let's
see here
yeah he gets whatever the max was
already
but divide by two so we could put this
in here like uh
like so
well this should be a plus
and
now we want to cast the entire thing to
an editor like so
and we need to scope this page hp to
warrior now this code is getting a
little ugly but if you really analyze it
you should be able to tell what's going
on
basically we're taking that base hp and
we're adding one level up let's get rid
of this well type here i don't know if
that's going to be too relevant
there we go
so now let's run this and make sure it
passes now we're dividing by a float
here so this turns to a float and then
it adds to an integer so we might have
some weird rounding stuff happen
occasionally here but in general
uh we could divide this by
or well trying to think of a way to do
this in a modular way that just like
goes off of level and there might be
some kind of formula we could say that
like add a number of the half base hp
times uh however many levels there have
been
but this is fine for now we could also
just hard code in here what it's
supposed to be we could put 18 and then
we could put whatever this is 27
etc
but you probably get the point and now
you know we've tested level one a little
bit we've tested level two
we could even do some more asserts in
here if anything else that we know for
sure should be and we basically want to
build this up as much as possible
and uh yeah
i'm going to leave it with that at that
for the warrior just so you have an idea
it kind of it should get the point
across well enough for you to continue
let's talk about making
more tests all right let's close all
this stuff for a second
so we have test method warrior test what
about test method
for something else well you just copy
this down uh i don't know what it's
doing with the syntax correction but
this one needs a different name you
can't have two of the same name so we
got warrior test let's have like a
i don't know we just got to come up with
something here maybe you know i've
already tested class you can do you can
test the other classes the same way it's
essentially the same thing you just use
whatever they are
so what else do we want to test let's
have a look at something here um
let's just go down the line
we could test some abilities that's a
little bit we'll probably come back to
that it's a little complicated because
uh we kind of need a little battle
system
we could test buffs
now we could just literally test the
creation of these abilities and buffs
and make sure that succeeds but these
more tie in with the players so it's
probably better to test them on a player
or something like that so i'm thinking
same with stats
we could test items and probably what we
want to do with items is fully test
whether they work with our backpack type
structures we could test the item
manager
and we could test these equip
and use functions for example uh there's
a lot of stuff and as you can see we
could write a lot of tests basically for
every function we could have a test so
let's just go ahead and do one for this
equip uh that's something we were
working on that pretty recently so let's
just go equip test all right and let's
make a class player character
uh just call this one player again and
let's do rogue this time it doesn't
really matter a lot oops what am i doing
that's like it's a
function definition this new rogue
i'm gonna put
there we go
and i'm just going to hit the formatting
key here to fix this all up a little
all right so let's do an equip test we
make a rogue well that should succeed
but now we want to give him an item so
what if we go
well let's just name this rogue
we want to equip
oh well we need to call equip separately
now equip is in item manager and we need
to include item manager to use it so
demo rpg
item manager
not sorting out the syntax
cannot open source file
nice oh i spelled manager wrong okay
let's fix that there we go so now we
should be able to go item
manager
whip
we need an item here
and then what we're equipping it to
we're equipping it to the road
now it needs a reference to the rogue so
that i can actually equip the step onto
them and the item here so
we have to do item manager
create
now let's create a weapon
and we need some some weapon stuff
i'm gonna get rid of this so this equip
is gonna test quite a few things here
like uh at some point we could try to
equip a potion and just confirm that it
fails because it should return false if
we try to equip potion we know that from
looking at our equip code all right
it's just uh moving forward it should
only return true if it's armor or weapon
if it falls through both of those to
return false so we could attempt to
equip a potion and just confirm that it
returns false that would be a fine test
sometimes you you do want to put the
fail cases in there as well just to make
sure
that it's failing as intended
so all right let's create this weapon
what does it want here uh
hopefully for a little autocorrect needs
a name uh we'll just call the dagger
sure
needs some c stats we're going to use
the constructor right here of course
that's uh which one
this one's fine let's actually just
leave it blank
it's not going to be a magical dagger or
anything and then we need a slot uh
that's going to be weapon slot
melee then we need a min and max damage
let's make it do one to three and two
hand is going to be false
just put that in there and now that it's
equipped we can assert that it's
equipped assert
i guess we would do is not null
i think here and it would be
uh rogue dot get
i think we have a get weapon at or get a
quick weapon at and then we need the
armor slot basically so weapon slot
melee
and now if we take a look at this a good
get equipped at it should return a
pointer to an item delegate
our equipment delegate i think we
actually want this to be
a weapon
and this one should be armor
yeah because the delegates can't be
instantiated that's that's not going to
work well all right let's go back to our
tests
it doesn't like this weapon saw melee we
need to cast it to the unsigned long
long
and that has to be you probably you
might remember from the episode where we
program these slots but
they're using arrays and arrays want the
type unsigned long long to access it
because this is essentially accessing an
array uh yeah check the armor
equipment's episode if you don't
remember how that goes but we already
went over all that
so we should just this should a turn
return a pointer an armor pointer and it
shouldn't be null or an armor a melee
weapon you know that slot should not be
null so that's all that this should do
right here so let's go ahead and just
hit uh run all tests again go to test
all right
test explorer
run all should find the new ones when
you hit run all and we should now have a
quick test pop up there there it is
quick test it seems to have passed it's
got a green check mark
and that is good all right so we can
continue on we could equip more stuff
let's just do a few more and then we'll
call it an episode
now let's do let's try a fail case let's
go
let's make a potion and equip that
no we'll call it armor pot and this is
going to be he wants different stuff
here of course
for the constructing
of a potion
uh yeah we'll call it armor pot that's
fine uh and then once a heal how much it
heals we're gonna say zero
quantity let's just give them one
and a buff pointer so here we need to
create a buff
so we could just go new buff
and uh
use one of these instantiations here
let's see which one do we want probably
just this one which takes a name
uh we just call it armor
it's called armor buff
and then it wants the duration how long
this arm above lasts let's say it lasts
i don't know five rounds
and then it wants some other stuff
now we're trying to use
see here we can flip through the
constructors it's kind of odd oh this
first thing should be core stats okay
so core stats and then
that's strength intelligence
agility
armor is what's going to buff how much
is going to buff the armor by i'll say
three element resistance zero just buffs
armor specifically
and then duration
uh yeah we're gonna say five rounds is
it deep up no it's not a debuff we mark
it as a debuff it'll subtract by three
armor because that's how we have that
program so there we go we got a little
buff that buffs
and an armor potion that buffs armor by
three for five rounds
and it's not a debuff okay
so
this has a default value i think we can
even just do it like that because it
defaults to false
so there we go that should uh i should
give him a button and now
this should fail
right so this when we call this equip it
should return false and this one should
be returning true
so what we actually should be doing here
is we should just be asserting
whatever its return value is so we just
should assert
that the equip dagger is true just like
so
oh
assert uh
is there an is true yeah it's true that
way we don't actually have to put true
in there
so we assert that the equip
dagger is true and then we can make
another assert and just assert that the
melee slot is uh
actually there it's not null
and then we can do this potion here
and we could just assert that this is
false so we're trying to equip potion it
shouldn't work
is
false
and we can go ahead and run this
very good it looks like everything was
successful
and all the equip tests passed
and all the warrior test pass so this is
just getting started as you can see he
can plug away this for a long time
in my experience
sometimes you'll have a guy just work
literally just build tests for
a long time it's like hey today
just work on building tests for
items just write as many can as you can
just try to go through every case
possible and put in the test that's your
duty today like that happens um
especially with like interns and stuff
because as you can probably imagine by
now you know we've already written the
code to do all this stuff and we in
theory know it works for us to kind of
write tests is
very boring menial tests at this point
so
but that's basically because we kind of
already know the code if someone doesn't
know the code very well tests are really
nice because you have to dig in and see
what all the code does and write test
for it so it's actually a great way to
learn the code bases just to basically
write tests for it if you're not all
that familiar with it and it's a great
way to get an understanding of what it
does too just to like walk through but
overall it's it's kind of one of the
more boring parts of coding in my
opinion some people might enjoy it more
than others but they're extremely
crucial and critical all right thanks
for watching i'll see you guys in the
next episode peace out
[Music]
you